solo work with a bunch of courses so
yeah I'm gonna talk about implicit
realization in an optimization throw in
learning and this is really something as
I mean I really think it's very
important and I hope to convince you
it's very important and I've been
developing both thinking of that from
the learning perspective today I'm going
to focus more on the optimization
perspective this is work with a bunch of
people in the over that mostly the past
two three years most of the work on
representing is these less - wait how
does it just early okay these nice two
papers one with the surya glance a car
who is here i think here lakewood worth
in this tree not the van der pol ii in
TTI and Venom who just moved to IES and
then another paper with Daniel Sedin
another firm soon Technion but many of
the examples I'm gonna show are also
take it from previous work for carbs
from TTI and from Berkeley so the place
I want to start this actually I'm
actually curious so I gave a talk in
this editorial in the previous program
of alcohol I'm gonna start the exactly
same place to start there just curious
how many people were in that I know some
of you were in that talk right okay
so don't worry there will be some new
stuff because I know you remember
everything from that talk but I want to
start actually an exact same place and
this is a experience I really like
because we don't understand it at all so
what we did here we we trained
a neural net between a bunch of new
units of different sizes so the x-axis
is the size of a network so it's smaller
network a bigger network an even bigger
network and we trained it just by
minimizing the the training error with
actually conjugate gradient descent all
the way to convergence and what we're
planning in black is the training error
so the first thing we see if the network
is too small doesn't have it can't
actually fit the data we don't have zero
training error and network website is
simply 64 hidden units is already big
enough to to get a training error and
there's an increase the size of the
network we still get to your training
error because we can fit the data and
the question is of course what happens
to the tester so initially the tester
drops because we can fit it you know we
can fit the data better and increase the
network size and the question for what
happens here what happens when we can
when we look at networks are two that
are larger than it's actually necessary
to fit our data mean so we're no longer
getting we're no longer decreasing the
bias we're no longer getting in better
fit we're no longer getting a better
approximation error but we're using a
class a larger class with higher
capacity yes
what is this measuring okay so this is
actually looking at not the the we were
looking at just miss classification
error zero wants efficient air it's not
actually a training objective well if
that what you're asking but you would
get the same so data are not be
returning through this distinction you
do over here get exactly the same thing
but this air this y-axis is actually
there's miss crucification air okay so
the question is what happens when you
look at larger networks so what what
should happen so we all know that once
I'm gonna use a network and modeled it's
too complicated my approximation is no
longer dropping my summation error is
going to increase or my variance is
going to increase and I'm gonna start
seeing an increase in it in the tester
and it's gonna over fit and in fact it
should over feed fit much more widely
than this it shouldn't go like this
because with a thousand Network with a
thousand units here already has more
training parameters than
the number of units and we can actually
get you can you can fit anything you
know no matter what the label is you can
use random labels you can fit them in an
8 Network the size so really this you
should get just through the roof test
area here so this is what yes you can
get I can get arbitrarily high test
error but yeah so you can get
description or if one there exists a
predictor that we'll get to that later
the exist predictor no so the thing if
you're doing your existence a particular
it has zero training gear in the stator
and hazard a tester of one okay
arbitrarily very close to one the thing
you can get half okay so okay so since
bin is a bit slow sometimes let's go
through this GUI this is not a cartoon
this is real data
now when you'll see a question when
appearing that means I'm asking a
question I'm asking is this what's gonna
actually appear because this is what we
think will appear this is a cartoon no I
told you this is what you'd expect what
you actually see is not this okay when
we actually see is actually this so the
training error keeps decreasing as we
increase the network size they're sorry
the tester keeps decreasing as we
increase the network sites and so
equation is what is what is gonna so
this is this is actually real data okay
this is actually this is not a cartoon
this is actually what we see so there
are two things here that are are so very
surprising and go against what we if you
just think of this so we have a model
and we're just minimizing and fitting it
by ear and by minimizing the training
our one is that why is the training
error continuing to drop here I mean
there's nothing no force that should be
making the training error drop here and
the second is why is it not like
completely skyrocketing here why are we
not overfitting wildly when we have
muddled class that that has higher
capacity than the number of the the
number of samples we have that they can
more
a number of samples can fit anything can
shatter the data we should not be
getting any type of generalization here
okay yes if we do robust training like
we make random perturbations to the
influence what do you think so that's a
form that's a form of organization and
if you also included rigor ization then
it could have maybe understood this
figure so in fact so in fact one one
explanation of what might be going on
here which is what what we're getting
here is that what what must be happening
here is that somehow even though what I
told you we're doing is just minimizing
the training er actually that's not what
the only thing that's going on and this
is this is gonna be the topic for this
talk that it seems it will do something
else that's like happening you're like
for example I'm getting more robustness
maybe I'm decreasing some norm or
something like that okay so let's try to
understand it that way and so this means
we actually showed this plot is I'm
surprised nobody now mention this
original case everybody actually this is
it looks a bit like boosting okay so
boosting in fact almost two decades ago
to ten kids ago
people are kind of confronted with a
similar type of strange behavior you're
on boosting and boosting brains in
particular it's increasingly more
complex as you progress in iterations
because includes
more so that the classic understanding
of boosting in terms of sparsely in
terms of the number of base predictors
and number four has crisp and number of
base predictors so any increase the
number of rounds you're increasing the
complexity and over here and think in
this example with and over the number is
six or seven rounds you already get zero
training error so you're not decreasing
same as before you're not decreasing the
bias you're not EP single proximation
error but you are actually decreasing
the tester and the explanation for it
and so so people were possibly why is
this happening I mean why am i why is
the main generalizing better even though
I'm using a more complex class and the
answer for boosting I know it is Peter
here actually okay so but paper by Peter
Bartlett and and rupture period and
another co-authors
the explanation is what's actually going
on here is the optimization the the
boosting is actually optimization
algorithm an optimization algorithm is
it's true that it's minimizing the
training error but
not only minimizing a training error
it's also increasing their one margin so
if you plot the l1 margin is function
Federation's so this is a plot taken
from paper so this is excessive is not
inverse situation but rather what I'm
plotting here is the behavior of the
margin the distribution of the margin
and the points as I for several
different points in algorithm so
initially for so for T equals 5 once I
guess when you get already zero training
error the margin is the margins are
pretty bad there's still a lot of points
of margin very far away from one and but
after more iterations a hundred and even
more so after a thousand iterations the
margin keep the margins keep increasing
so the l1 margin provides an explanation
for what is actually going on here so
what we see here is two things first of
all the optimization algorithm namely
adaboost is actually doing two things
it's both decreasing the training error
which is what it was originally
developed to do but it's also increasing
the l1 error the l1 margin which is not
something that was initially developed
to do I mean for I'm pretty sure then
when rubbish appeared and your friend
rupture developed adaboost
their goal they didn't we're not
thinking of in terms of l1 margin all
their goal was just okay we have a
training here you want to get it to zero
okay but it is actually doing that in
the second as we understand now how
we're getting better translation because
we're having the lower complexity model
and complexity smaller one or better l1
margin okay so this is what you kind of
try 1 understand oh so yes that's true
but when you get better sorry I don't
want to talk too much about boosting the
situation here is actually a bit complex
and I'll try to paint a crisper picture
for the problem so I'm actually going to
look at but when you get if you get
better margin on the on the training
data that does translate into better
translation guarantees or can translate
into better translation guarantees so
particularly the way you really should
think about it is you're decreasing the
l1 or you're getting a predictor with
lower complexity okay so if I if I could
you know if I really wanted to plug-in I
should we've plotted you the l1 the
normalized l1 norm here in fact that's
exactly what we're going to try to do so
we go back to our data and you can say
okay this is this is exactly that plot
from the first site except I'm focusing
only an area here where they have zero
training err because really the only the
mystery is only what happens when the
regime william zero training error when
the training error is decreasing that's
not not interesting you know what
happens there
and now we can say okay mr. ization
you're improving because we're getting
better because we're we're decreasing
the norm okay so maybe our algorithm is
somehow implicitly decreasing norm so we
can plug the norm and if the norm is
decreasing we can say okay the
complexity in terms of the norm is
decreasing and that's why we're getting
better generalization what's the what's
architecture here it's some three-layer
it's very simple it's very very simple
yeah that's in your honor so this is a
been your your let me show it and then
you can ask this question is second okay
so if I plug the if I plug the norm then
the norm the norm is actually so this is
the first thing we did and the norm is
not decreasing it's actually increasing
so it does explain what's going on but
then we have a smart s in the front row
that's what's the wooden what norms
letting there a bunch of norms so this
this norm that we're plotting here is
just the overall the overall $2
Frobenius norm just have some square for
the weights in the system and that's
just a bad norm to capture what's going
on in your own it's okay so I can
convince you why it's a bad norm that's
the topic of a different talk I mean
well one reason it's about norms it's
not invariant to kind of rescaling if I
take this network for example has very
high norm but if I just rescale each
layer by a different constant and get a
completely equivalent networking that
much lower norm so the lawn doesn't
really capture the complexity of what's
going on so what we can do instead is
this is invent a different norman we can
invent a bunch of different norms and
actually in there we have and some of
these are not even actually norms but
you can have manage measures so I'm just
going to show you one of them we have a
whole we have an entire paper coming out
and upcoming nips where it's no paper is
about inventing norms and testing them
so but this is for one no the Cathar
it's not so important for this talk what
exactly definition is the point if when
they plot the path norm the paestum it
does capture a bit more the computations
going on if I do the same plot and put
the path norm then now lo behold the
pass term is actually decreasing so it
means that in that I could understand
what's going on here by saying by two
things first of all the reason I'm
improving generalization is because I'm
actually finding a simpler model simpler
in what way not simpler in the sense
that it has smaller parameters has more
parameters but simpler in this hesitant
sense it has smaller norm
okay and because of that I can get
better
and guarantees they can't actually get
generalization guarantees in terms of
the norm and the other thing is they can
explain understand what's going on here
when you have okay so okay so that let's
do good and then you can also look at
another thing so this is I have this
line here yeah okay so this is
especially for Ben Ben and Moritz and
co-authors is sunny and Ramon had had a
nice nice paper recently in which they
showed how really you can on these
networks you can fit they do have a very
high capacity you can you take the same
amount of training that you use random
labels and you can still fit the random
labels even though you're not
generalizing so now you can ask okay
does the norm does the path norm really
explain generalization in that sense
okay so what what you can do is plot as
a function of your training set size
take different training set sizes and
fit real data and fit junk so you can
fit both the real data in the junk the
real data is going to generalize well
the junk will obviously not they both
have the same complexity in terms of
number of parameters but now you can see
what is the complexity of the resulting
model in terms of the norm and indeed
the the norm for the junk to required to
fit the junk is increasing polynomial e
at least from what you can see from this
slide increasing polynomial e with the
amount of label data were fitting which
makes sense this is path norm since
we're really we're fitting junk the cup
that we expect the pack capacity to
increase with the number of examples
whereas we're fitting real data the the
norm kind of plateaus which again makes
sense because you know to fit real data
once we have enough capacity to fit our
actual real distribution we don't need
to increase capacity when you increase
number of examples because the x-axis is
different the x-axis is completely
different here the x-axis number of
hidden units in here x-axis it's
training set size okay it's two
completely different ones
here it's a 1000 I think you're this is
this is okay okay okay these are
completely different
okay wait these two plots are for two
completely different experiments this is
this is taking the the network from
Ben's paper which is a much bigger and
more complicated Network okay
and and this is for a very simple 3
layer Network okay so it's it's these
top two plots alright don't confuse me
but anyway this is just a side point
let's go to a more interesting question
okay what's going on you so he said with
a thousand point you would already a
thousand a thousand units I can I got
that we we're in gradient descent and
conjugate gradient descent and what we
found is this point that generalizes
pretty well has two percent test error
it also has very small path norm okay
but the thing is that with 1000 point
with 1000 units and the amount of
training that I'm using here I actually
can get in there many ways what we did
was minimizing the training err there
are many ways of minimizing the training
err with one with for this amount of
data and this network size so in other
words there many global Optima off the
training girl remember our training here
is just minimizing the training error
okay and and I'm I'll show you so
there's several others here so for
example all these points here that I'm
planning you know our global minimum of
the training error all of them are 0
error solutions zero training error
solutions
but many of them have very high path
norm in fact most of them in some sense
a very high caste norm and in fact they
don't generalize well at all Mazen they
have in not only that have tested a bit
worse than half they actually can get
them really have test error as close as
a 1 to 1 and since very close to 1 and
so there's something special going on
here that what we said we're doing is
just minimizing the training error but
we're not just minimizing a training err
because we're analyzing a training earth
and we could be choosing this point at
this point at this point which would not
be generalizing well what we're actually
doing is dressing it minimizing the
training error and then also you know
something is causing us also to minimize
the path norm the question is what is
what's minimizing the custom here and
then again I'm not actually claiming the
path arm is being minimized but
something related to
bathroom probably so it seems that we're
gaining from a lot what we did is just
minimize an unregulated objective and
we're seems to be where the summary
realization going on here where seems to
be benefiting a lot from some implicit
form of organization now for we do I
definitely understand the connection how
optimization can get you implicitly
realization so I understand it very well
for stochastic or online or surf one
past methods or at least with early
stopping in for context methods we
understand this very analytically in
precisely so when you do when you run
when you minimize the training or just
the training or without any explicit
organization using something extra
caster gradient descent and you do one
pass over the data then you can benefit
from generalization properties with
respect to the l2 norm and you say this
connection between STD and l2 norm and
if you use different optimization
algorithms you can get different
implicitly realization in fact for any
implicit bias that allows you to learn
then you can there's a potential
function so that if you do stochastic
mirror descent with that potential
function you would benefit from that
implicit bias so you can do in some
sense any learning just by using
unrealized mirror descent with some
appropriate potential function so so
this we understand very well and what I
want emphasize here again there's a
connection between the choice of
organization algorithm and the implicit
bias I'm getting in the implicit
organization that's going on so we
understand this very well for convex
problems when you stochastic
optimization but what's going on here is
we're not using stochastic optimization
we're not doing early stopping we're
actually using the term monistic
optimization we could have used
stochastic but we're optimizing all the
way to converging to convergence without
any early stopping and we're still
gaining from a lot of implicit
organization and the reason we're
getting this implicit organization is
because the problem is highly under
determined there are lots of global
minima and we're getting not to just
some global minima but we're getting to
a very specific global minima so
optimization algorithm here is doing
much more than just minimizing the
training error what the optimization
algorithm is doing is actually
minimizing training and also selecting
from among all the minimizer of the
training error a very specific global
minima to go to and what I want to talk
about in this talk is this so so in
examines this is playing here a crucial
or in a crucial role in learning all my
learning all my inductive bias is not
coming from the model class because the
model class can fit anything I mean the
model
I can I can fit random labels so that
model class small class is not really
constraining me not giving me any
inductive bias all the inductive bias is
coming from stimulation algorithm and
that also means in particular if I
choose a different optimization
algorithm on the exact same optimization
objective the exact same problem the
exact same optimization objective I'll
get a different bias and so different
realization properties and you can
definitely see this in practice so this
is nice so this is what we did is we do
take that same path norm and you know
steepest ascent approximate steepest
ascent respect to that path norm instead
of SGD and so this is we call this path
you see in this blue line this is the
actual training objective both both
paths SVG and SGD gets zero training
error they both solve your permutation
problem if you're concerned about
optimization both of them are fine okay
path the streams they may be a bit
faster but not by more than a factor of
two okay so both of them were fine are
fine but when you go to the test error
you see a huge difference between them
path SGD actually finds generalize is
much better so it finds a much better
global minima what does it mean like
much better global minima again in terms
of optimization you know if you ask Alex
sorry you can you you know an
optimization perspective both global
minima they're both good I can you can't
you can't tell them one is better
another for implementation perspective
but one of them is but clearly path
surgery is better in terms of learning
in terms of generalization performance I
mean you see this also I brought you
these it's it's approximate steepest
descent with respect to the pasture it's
a different optimization algorithm just
just take it for now is different
optimization algorithm okay another
example is if you compare stochastic
gradient descent to adaptive methods I
gotta graduate them so both at a grad
both Adam and STD what both STD in both
HCG and Adam and I regret succeed and
minimize the training error okay so in
terms of optimization they're both doing
good job maybe a bit faster maybe a bit
small in this example Adam is actually a
bit faster in other in other experiments
actually Adam at the end at least is not
any faster but once we go to the to the
testing error we can see a huge
difference SGD actually converges to a
much better global minima
grow the minimum then Adam it gets a
much better generation so some of the
inductive bias introduced by HUD for
free training the sleep network is much
better inductive bias an inductive bias
and should display item and a degrade
would behave the same here right yeah
okay so these are these are experiments
by Beck I was over there you can is many
experiments also about here about an in
the paper but with other problem you see
this pretty consistently in your that's
so okay so what's going on here so the
thing is that saying that our that
there's a lot going on an optimization
algorithm the optimization algorithm is
playing a crucial role so one one way to
think about it is when talking about
learning there's a you frequently think
of okay we're gonna come up with some
models say that our learning is
happening by minimizing the training
Karen and we've just find optimization
are going to minimize the training her
so you get papers at La Crosse we like
this this is you put the typical machine
learning paper one anyway so you come up
with some architecture and then you say
okay how are you going to learn this
architecture great the way you're going
to learn is you're going to minimize the
training error in this architecture and
this is your learning rule you're
learning method okay and then yeah this
is not this is this is an older paper
this is from where more than two months
ago okay so you're gonna and you're
gonna minimize and so your learning rule
you're defining your learning role as
minimizing your training error and
that's your learning rule and then you
say okay I'm gonna optimize it some
method even doesn't matter up don't I
said I may be able be faster may be
smaller this is my learning rule and
then you the experience states works
great and what I'm claiming is this view
of learning completely misses the point
because this is not your learning method
your learning method is actually over
here your learning method is how you
chose to optimize this if you changed
how we optimize this you'll get a
different learning method okay and and
so it's important here to a realizes and
then if this is the case you really
should understand what is this actually
doing this paper doesn't say what didn't
what this method is doing it doesn't
tell me what the inductive biases it
doesn't characterize the learning rule
it just gives some like obscure
procedure in here that have to read the
source code
understand what it's doing to even
understand what the learning rule is not
just how its implemented
yes I'm not saying the loss function is
not important at all
or are not saying it's not important the
loss function is important but where the
thing is that by itself doesn't is not
does not paint the complete picture and
that's not just it's missing some
details it's missing the entire thing
okay so okay so again the the if I
change in optimization algorithm changes
the biased and resisted by the
optimization algorithm this is really
what's driving learning and so in this
talk and we're really gonna so how the
bias affects generalization that's
that's for a different talk I mean we
can also talk about that what we're
gonna be talking about this talk is
trying to relate the optimization
algorithm by trying to understand for
each optimization algorithm what is the
bias it's actually introducing you
roughly can think of it the picture as
follows so all these problems are huge
underdetermined problems I mean they
have many global minima okay and what
how many infinite continuum continuum of
global minima okay they have tons of
global minima and you're gonna and so
this is the peculiar idea you're
starting over here and now depending on
your optimization algorithm either
you're gonna get to a global minima over
here this is what happens in this case
with the coordinate descent and this is
grading descent you're gonna get to go
to a different global Optima here what
you want to characterize exactly which
is well you're gonna get to another way
to think about it so think of these
global in these under internment
problems they're all non-negative
objectives and you can think of there
but they have many zero errors you can
think of this as the oceans we have tons
of oceans and you're gonna start
optimizing at a top of some hill and
you're gonna use your favorite
optimization algorithms I'm gonna go
down so if you start optimizing in
Berkley you're probably going to get to
the bay okay probably no matter what
optimization are going to use and if you
start optimizing in Boston you're
probably gonna get the left antique
ocean if you're gonna start optimizing
in Chicago and now we're gonna get so
now it depends on the optimization
algorithms what
but no but Michigan is not a global
minima Lake Michigan is like 200 feet
about Syria about sea level position but
that's that's actually wrong because
it's not clear gonna get to Lake
Michigan because if you come to Chicago
you see that Chicago is so flat in fact
I'm serious
right so Chicago is actually I mean the
Chicago River flows again away from the
Commission again right so it's not so
obvious I get to Lake Michigan and which
of them is a Chanel beam to use is going
to determine them you can even also
think of it in terms of you know
geometry what is the kind of geometry
optimization I believe is going to
determine kind of which way you're gonna
go and that's really going to determine
how are you girl it's so-so
so this is where we're going to talk
about today yes because over here for
example the same prioritization I can do
either gradient descent Amir or
accordion descend I'll get two different
places so the privatization definitely
plays a role so so what's I would argue
is important here because the overall
geometry which is given in terms of the
prioritization but also your geometry
inside that parameter space so it's
really es ok but let's let's look at
specific example so this is kind of the
blabber part of the talk and now now I'm
going to hit you with some equations so
what we're gonna be looking at today is
I'm going to show specific examples of
translational gifts I'm trying to
understand what their implicit biases so
we're gonna start with linear regression
it couldn't be simpler then we're going
to move on to metrics characterization
models and logistic regression so let's
start with the new regression so this is
maybe the simplest possible example
we're just under the term and linear
regression squared loss me and me and
the problems are determined there are
many zero solutions what everything fine
did I get something wrong here Lebanon I
flipped a minute I'm sorry M is much
less than n sorry sir I flipped them in
any here okay M is much less than n so
many fewer observations then then
dimensionality and the question is what
happens when I opt amaizing sued grand
indecent what am I going to get to so
it's relatively easy to see that if I
started the origin optimized with grand
in descent
or any reasonable variant of gradient
descent from momentum conjugate gradient
ascent BFGS STD you name it and let it
converge not just to any global minima
but I'm going to converge to the minimum
normal solution you know l 2-norm
solution I mean we'll see a more formal
perfect this soon but basically what's
going on here is that I remain in the
span of the data and the unique solution
that's inspired for the Uniqlo block and
it's in spent for the data it's exactly
a middle normal solution okay so this is
exactly the type of theorem word like to
characterize which global optimum and
certain optimization algorithm reaches
even though there are many go block them
okay so let's move on from simple least
squares good student talk about means
simple squares but now we're just gonna
make this argument W metrics argument so
we're talking about metrics metrics V
squared okay so now you have a W and you
have a linear objective over W bunch of
linear measurements you can think of it
the simplest way to think about is
metrics completion where each one of
these observations just with a single
entry but you can also think of its
multitask learning or metrics your
construction or your favorite linear
problem with metrics argument and the
problem is again gonna be under the term
n did I get it right here yeah I did get
it right here okay so a number of
observations is much less than the size
of metrics much s and N squared
you know maybe roughly in okay and so
there are many global minima here and
there are lots of really trivial global
minima so if you think of metrics
completion right this problem is like
that stupid I mean you can just complete
the observed entries and impute
everything to zero or impute everything
just 37 or whatever you want right you
don't you can't this is completely
senseless okay and actually that's what
you get also here when you're grading
descendant W so if you do gradient of W
I'm gonna get with from metrics
completion problem that's exactly what
I'm gonna get imputed everything to 0 so
that's no good but instead of we're
gonna still looking an exact problem
exact same problem but instead of
writing it this way I'm just gonna write
W as u times V then I'm but I'm not
gonna constrain the dimensionality of U
and V so u and V are both full
dimensional so this means that this
problem is completely equivalent to the
problem I had before any metrics I can
write as u times V so I didn't change
the problem the argument the
minimization problem is exactly the same
it has all the same trivial use this
global minima and I can still complete
put in the observed entries and impute
everything else to zero mean and the
question is what happens when you
minimize
minimize U and V by gradient descent hmm
now of course the reason the real other
two reasons were interested in this
problem one is because matrix
factorization in matrix operations may
be important but the real reason we're
interested in problem is because we want
to understand what's going on in deep
learning and this is deep learning and
this is a neural network with you know
depth 2 layer network with linear
transfer so if we can't understand this
it's leave learning if we can't
understand this we can't understand deep
learning okay so let's let's start here
and see if we can understand this at
least ok ok so when we're actually going
to do is is a so irrelevant here is not
symmetric doesn't understand but that we
understand for gradient descent hiding
descent so ok least-squares gradient
descent with the we understand the
performance of grainy descend early
squares so other algorithms it's true
that we will get back to that later but
at least gradient descent on these
squares we understand I understand I
think you do too
ok ok ok so we're actually going to look
at it's actually gonna be simpler for us
to look at symmetric factorization of a
symmetric characterization so basically
the only constraint is imposes the
metrics is WS PSD it's actually both
more general or just simpler they're
less letters to write on the board so
let's look at symmetric equations ok so
now we can ask if we optimum if we do
gradient is selling with U and V this is
this actually sensible ok can we
actually generalize and again what i'm
doing here i'm gonna solve omit the
metrics completion of matrix a
construction from linear measurements
problem completely under determined ok
I'm not imposing any constraint and U
and V all I'm doing is optimizing U and
V by gradient ascent and what we get is
the following so the training error so
we train using different optimization
methods gradient descent this is
gradient descent on X ok these three
methods I'll talk about in a second or
grading different versions of gradient
descent on you and this is actually the
minimum nuclear norm solution so we've
never forget this for now
first of all the training error is zero
and often we got golden four of them
whole point when we look at how's the
test performance look like so gradient
descent on X we already know is really
horrible
it gets you to really trivial global
minima that the
not generally as well amazingly if you
optimize using gradient descent on U and
V without again any constraint or any
explicit organization you and we are
full dimensional there's no around
constraint here no nothing you actually
do generalize great you reconstruct your
your matrix so it doesn't though didn't
seem to matter exactly in a step size
policy and initialization so this was
not the case for grading for at least
square pond where it didn't depend on
the step size here we see so this is
gradient descent with exact line search
it still gets pretty pretty good tests
are much better than than junk but not
zero in order to get really zero
training error I have to have very small
step sizes in the green box is
initialized far away from the origin
these are both initialization matters in
the step size the tiny step size with
initialization far away from the origin
okay not very good okay okay so what's
going on here and one thing that might
be going on here is that the that what
may be being minimized is the nuclear
norm so you can plot with the nuclear
norm for each of these we can indeed see
then in fact I mean then the
optimization does drive us towards lower
in your cleanroom solutions and this we
actually skipped this experiment because
we don't have much time this leads to a
fall in conjecture that roughly speaking
with Ukrainian descent factorization we
converge nothing mini minimum Frobenius
norm solution but their minimum nuclear
norm solution but in order for that to
happen we need two things we need the
initialization to be close to zero now
the problems we can't initialize at zero
okay because zero is the saddle point
all right so so we can never move
anything so we have to initialize close
to zero and we have to take very small
step sizes that's kind of an informal
conjecture yes oh oh sorry yeah X and W
are the same I thought I changed all the
XS to w WN x sorry so this is a mixed
right this is mixed mixed crowd but
optimization and learning and learning
so i can use both w NX
there's no better as i think here but w
NX are the same thing
they forbid not exactly we will not
actually converge the minimum for being
a storm in a few you're right that if
you minimize a for minister a few then
you are minimizing the nuclear norm of W
but not necessarily for a symmetric
organization know so for symmetric
characterization it is true yes yes
sorry for a non symmetric realization
that's not the case okay okay so to make
to state this more formally we're gonna
we're going to talk about a few decimal
step size so in order to talk about
phantasmal step sizes I'm going to talk
about the gradient flow so this is just
what happens we take the step size to
zero you get the differential equation
that the dynamics of U is given by the
negative gradient and you can write this
explicitly and what we what's going on
here okay and so you should just write
this explicitly and what you get here is
that you evolves according to you
multiply it in the left by some linear
transformation of the residuals so the
more interesting thing is now we can
write also the dynamics and X so the
optimization here and soon to define in
terms of dynamics in you but you can ask
what are the induced dynamics on U times
u transpose so what you get is the
dynamics of you are just if you just use
the the chain rule you get you can write
in terms of dynamics there are X and W
in terms of X and U but note that these
things are just W themselves so that
means that you can write the dynamics of
W independent of the factorization
depending of the choice of accusation
and this is actually this is something
that's special because you're taking a
gradient flow if you're taking finite
step sizes which vectorization you have
would actually influence your your
dynamics but here we can just think of
in dynamics of W so these are not a
gradient in epochs of W we can specify
dynamics on W that are induced by the
gradient dynamics in you okay okay and
now we initialize W not very close to
zero and ask what is this specific
specific organization what where did the
dynamics and go to the limits so this is
what gradient flow converges and the
the formal conjecture here is that if we
take any full rank initialization and
scale it close to zero so we initialize
in any direction close to zero and we
follow these dynamics if we actually
convert you to a global minima then this
global minima is a special goal minimum
it's exactly a nuclear-armed solution
okay so this is a conjecture we don't
yet know how to prove this we know how
to prove what I mean how much time do I
have actually okay we do know so to give
you a sense of it how we might prove
this what we'll see is how to prove this
for the case we can which is when these
AIS commute meso and observation
mattresses commute that's not a very
interesting case in some sense I mean no
no interesting metrics problem is
captured by this case alex is making a
face rightfully so okay but it still
gives a suggestion of how we might go
about proving this and also there is an
interesting vector problem that is
captured by this so we good even this
corollary I think is interesting so
suppose you are minimizing a vector
least square problem but you're it's not
interesting there's no X here somebody
should invent a PowerPoint macro that
changes all the WS to X's okay so so you
have the vector least square problem and
we're minimizing and using gradient
descent but instead of grading center W
we're going to parent your eyes W since
we're interested in non negative
solutions we're gonna in parent eyes W
is U squared integrating Square and on
you so that's kind of a a plausible way
of solving a non negative least squares
problem and if you do that you actually
converge to the minimum what what what
this implies is that when you do that
you actually convert to min and l1 norm
solution right I mean a real to norm
solution okay fine so I'm just trying to
squeeze an interesting corollary on the
not very interesting theorem here but
the main point here is not to get this
corollary but really is a step to
handling the general case in the general
case it cannot offer your proof I can
offer you a bunch of hand
waving and some empirical evidence and I
will do the head waving in a bit and if
you want then the empirical evidence you
have to look at our paper okay so how do
we prove this so to start let's go back
to this grading sign on W which is
basically the vector case and and how do
we prove here that you can virtual manor
Frobenius norm solution so we're gonna
start at zero okay
and in okay so I'm gonna show that we
could get to the minimum use no solution
so the main observation here is that we
said W stays always in the span of the
data why is that so we can define a
manifold and this is just in this case
the manifold spanned by your data and at
any point we're at the gradient is
always a tangent to this manifold okay
in this case this manifold just a flat
manifold is just a subspace and so the
direction of the gradient flow is going
to be always inside this new tangent in
this manifold which means the graining
path will remain inside this manifold so
we always stay inside this manifold I
mean how you can leverage that so we
want to prove that we actually solve
this optimization problem implicitly so
what we're going to just write the KKT
condition for this optimization problem
ever this is not the optimization
problem on which we're doing writing
descent this is optimization problem on
which we claim we implicitly that we
implicitly are solving so the KKT
conditions in this case are just primal
optimality sorry yeah primal feasibility
and this dual condition the any new
equals W is the dual variable okay so
okay so note that whenever whenever
we're on the manifold okay then W is
equal to exactly a s so we can so s is
always a dual certificate for this
second KKT condition so this is
satisfied for any point in a manifold
and when we are and we know that
Grandison will actually converge to the
optimum and when which is an optimum
then we also have feasibility so we
satisfy both of the KKT conditions and
we can conclude that when getting this
and converges to the minimum of this
problem or in other words whenever I
know that the the exact grading AMEX
here not so important what's important
is just whenever I stay on this manifold
if I find any global minima on this
manifold it's going to actually
so the the be the middle Norma solution
okay this is a slightly over complicated
proof for what we already knew but let's
see now how we can use the same the same
approach also for our metrics problem
and let's start from the case within a
single observation okay so a single
observation then my dynamics are just
given in terms of the residual times the
observation times W plus the sorry
there's a t here here this is should be
a WT okay and I can actually this is
just a differential equation I can solve
explicitly and the solution is given by
this experimentation form so it's a
transformation of the observation times
initial point times matrix equation and
other side and how much exponentiate I
have to just keep track of the residuals
well it turns out this is not so
important what we're gonna again look at
the problem we want to solve in writes
its KKT conditions so now we have we
have four okay so we have four
conditions here and this we don't have
to worry about our solution we always
VPS D and at the optimum we're gonna get
and we're gonna when we reach it
actually the greatest and we know is
going to converge to something that's
going to satisfy this so we'd only care
about the blue ones okay
now getting the blue ones is gonna be a
bit trickier but now it's gonna be
important that we actually optimize a
actually initialize close to zero so
initialize close to zero well let's see
it what happens here this is a solution
we know we're gonna get to WT that has
finite magnitude and W zero is gonna
have many it goes to zero as it goes to
zero so this thing has to have infinite
magnitude in there or in other words st
has to go to infinity
but if st goes to infinity then the only
thing that survives out of this exponent
are the leading eigen directions of a
and so that means that WT is spanned by
the leading eigen direction League in
leading eigen directions of a I'd leave
it so W infinity spend by those with
maximum value with the directions of a
that has have maximum eigen value and
base now I can construct the DOE
certificate so if I just look at the
door here to the scalar is one over the
in value I see that what does it mean
that a spender leading eigen direction
that so aw is just the the eigenvalue
times aw you're fine right okay and i
satisfy this doe condition and also
because we're scaling a satisfying my
module feasibility constraint
okay so again what we've shown in again
at the limit i satisfy oh so these gazes
and i'm done so what we showed here is
that it's not whoa back back back what
we showed here so let's see how this
proof went it's no longer that we have
still manifold and we're staying within
this men ho this manifold their solution
of this form it's not not the case that
solutions on this manifold satisfies
these little conditions it will only
become the case when initialization goes
to zero so as the initialization goes to
zero any point in the solution manifold
that's far away from zero is going to
satisfy the dual conditions and the
primal conditions we get kind of for
free okay and now we can do the exact
same thing for general if you have many
measurements as long as they all commute
because if all the measurements commute
they can still solve this differential
equation and the solution has this form
if again we have a matrix exponentiation
if there's a linear combination of
matrices and i'm not going to go
carefully through all the details but we
exactly do the same thing when the
initialization goes to 0 the magnitude
of this has to go to infinity and i'm
dominated by deleting item components so
now it's not reading outcome components
of one a but some linear combination of
the a's i can define get a dual
certificate oops
all over the place sorry I can get a
dual certificate and I can get it to a
certificate and again establish a KKT
conditions okay so again what we can
prove is that if the measurements
commute then our conjecture is true
namely gradient descent converges to the
minimum solution now even here we
already see several interesting things
this results similar to the gradient
descent case is independent of the
steering
Mayson depending of the residuals it's
not really important that I do exactly
gradient descent all I have to do is
make sure that at each step I state
engine to this manifold so so the loss
so it's not important with the losses I
can change that means that I can change
the squared loss to
any loss any smooth loss smooth non-
loss with the unique finite route okay
right right so that and you know and
this will still work or I can do all
kinds of things like stochastic gradient
descent or momentum or all these things
still stay with that within this no
momentum I can't do sorry I can just do
castigating descent or all kinds of
weightings and still stay within this
manifold what I cannot do is do momentum
because when it whenever mentum you know
I kind of hop off the manifold not to
imagine that I have my manifold this my
manifold is flat like it was for grading
descent then if I have momentum and I
kind of overshoot in some way I still
stay in the manifold right now in the
momentum is curved then if I have
momentum I'm gonna do a ski jump and go
off my manifold I also cannot take
finite steps because again I'm gonna
take finite steps they go off the
manifold and this is sort of where do
you see the difference here between the
similar grading these centrally square
bombs where it's fine to do momentum and
grading descent in this case where it's
more delicate we do have to get an
infinitesimal step size and we cannot do
we cannot in introducing momentum will
actually change what we converge to okay
so this is what we can prove what you
really would like to prove is the
general case they're prone in the
general case I can characterize the
solution and the solution is given by
this time ordered exponential so the
time or experience is kind of similar to
an integral so an integral is a limit of
summation this is a limit of a product
and what we really would like to do is
just put this product inside the
exponent and make it a sum we can only
do that if things are if the
observations commute if they don't
commit we cannot do that and we don't
know how to analyze this thing in
particular the manifold approach is not
gonna work here so in general you
actually can have crazy steering we can
no longer say we don't care about the
residuals if you do you if I take this
problem and to have been instead of the
real residuals your some very crazy
string but the crazy string has to be
really ridiculously crazy I actually can
get to any metrics okay so in particular
I can get to matrices and do not satisfy
the the dual conditions in practice this
doesn't happen with any reasonable
steering either the correct steering
from the residuals or steering taken
residuals taken from some other problem
or any other residuals you can possibly
like
somebody generate that I was not
ridiculously crazy then once you get far
enough from the origin you do satisfy
the dual condition and this is what we
suspect happens here that roughly
speaking if the steering is not
completely crazy and then hopefully you
can prove that the residuals are not
completely crazy then you actually get
to a point that satisfies the two
conditions in a nuclear arm solution but
we don't know again we don't know how to
do this so again this is the situation
now we can prove this conjecture for the
communitive case we are hoping to prove
it for the general case very recently
like yesterday I heard from Tanguma that
together with the students they actually
made progress in a general case but
under the with a different proof
technique and under the conditions that
they met the myth that the problem is
generated by a low rank metrics within
coherent measurements so really that
everything we said we did not until now
require that the problem is you know in
coherence and anyway as a solution we
just got to say we get to the median
optimal solution I didn't tell you the
mean whether we couldn't nuclear
solution is actually any good or not
what thank you and the students showed
is that if we are actually in this good
situation
then they can prove an approximate
version at least of the general
conjecture okay so this is metrics
characterization let's switch to
something will be actually easier what
how much time they have doing that tough
time 10 minutes that's fine you already
asked questions okay so okay so let's
talk about logistic regression okay so
just aggregation almost as simple as
these squares okay what happens so these
are just a question what happens if I
minimize logistic regression using
gradient descent okay and specifically
so just regression linear separable data
right so Danya is separable okay what
happens where would where this gradients
and converge almost
but that's not exactly true okay so okay
okay so converges to a global Optima
okay I didn't ask you okay
so what is gradient descent confirm what
so okay so what is variance in reversing
its receptor we ask we have to ask us
what is the government in this case and
there's no government in the global
minima is not attainable I mean the
infimum is of the loss is zero but it's
only attained at infinity so gradient
ascent will actually not converge
grandson will diverge to infinity right
and so what you really should be asking
yourself is within which direction
there's a diverge so I would say that
this cost function is good exactly
because I can you know we because John
is right there's got some extra margin
solution okay really let's go so let's
go to this a bit slower so that other
than John those others can understand
what's going on so the plane is a
gradient divergence but the question is
in which direction there's a diverge or
in other words where does the normal
normalization of the solution converge
to and as john guessed correctly after
reading the paper but you probably could
have guessed with our before reading the
paper so this is definitely the first
guest at anybody if anybody did not
guess this then you should improve your
guesses so so you do in fact go to the
maximum margin solution but note that
this is I mean this is something that we
we shouldn't take for granted because
this is not the minimizer of the loss
right I mean we didn't have margin
anywhere in the loss we just talked
about logistic logistic regression
logistic loss you know does not impose
some specific margin and we definitely
didn't have the l2 I mean of course
they'll talk up some great any sense so
people that you serve the statement if
you normalize you're gonna go you're
gonna converge to a normalization of w
hat where w hat is maximum arjun
solution what is in mexico margin it's
the just a second it's a solution hey
Jonathan
he's making sure other people also
understand John so the it's just a hard
margin SVM solution right so the minimum
l2 solution subject everything is
so is separating the march of one yes
John
if I just use exponential or something
do I get the same result yes because
this where is it because this holds not
only for the logistic loss there's
nothing super special about the logistic
costs this actually holds for any loss
with a with the exponential the way that
the negative gradient has an exponential
takes okay so this is the statement so
this is a statement here it holds for
any so definitely the the important
thing is the loss has to be monotone
decreasing and not negative and positive
right so you never have you never have
to reach zero there's no be monotone
decreasing right because once you reach
zero then this is deafening you're not
gonna get the next margin because you're
gonna get stuck and also in order to
prove this at least we have to use the
fact that it's exponential the the
gradients potentially the cake okay but
the other thing we can show here is I
want to talk about these two points one
is we can characterize not only where it
converges to but how it you know how
fast it goes there right so WT is gonna
scale is this max margin solution times
log T plus something that's bounded okay
your character is it very finally we can
even characterize this art this bounded
residual even more or finally in the
second is that this result unlike the
great onions in this query so this is
completely independent of a starting
location and the step size of T is so to
first
so what row ft couldn't I need a
slightly more conditions and then Rho of
T what Rose T converges to so what I can
show just based on these conditions is
Rho of T is bounded with anymore
condition Rho of T I can tell you what
Rho of T converges to and what it
converges to us also independent of the
step size and initial conditions margin
solution sure
of course this is extremely slow
you know this is this is extremely bad
way of maximizing margin so let's get to
that but let's let's get to that
actually uh okay let's skip the proof
sketch and just get to the so so I think
the interesting thing here so the summe
the fact that it converges a max margin
solution who is not so surprising I mean
if you give me one guess also I'd guess
like most of you did I get to the max
margin solution it's still nice to see
that really holds in this bra generality
and without requiring your doesn't
matter initialization in the step size
but what's much more surprising to me is
the speed of convergence which is very
slow so both in terms of how quickly we
converge to the max margin solution in
terms of how quickly do maximize the
margin both of them behave is one over
log T and you should contrast this with
how quickly the last converges so the
loss converges is 1 over T which means
that the margin converges exponentially
slower than the loss itself now this is
very important because this tells us
that when we're doing with loss we
actually use for training neural nets is
actually logistic loss or soft max which
is basically logistic and what this
tells us that even after the loss is
extremely small we still worthwhile to
continue optimizing and now we
understand why it's worthwhile continue
optimizing because even after their loss
is extremely small we're still improving
the margin because the margin is
converging much much slower than the
loss and we see this we can see this
empirically but I'll take your question
in a second we can see this empirically
so this is results so important point
out two things here these are results in
training a neural net this is not
covered by the theory because it's not
actually in your model but we definitely
see the same type of behavior so we see
two things here one is that the training
loss decreases you know even after the
training loss is already very very tiny
and and very small it's still worthwhile
continue optimizing because presumably
were we're improving the martin we're
still continuing to improve the margin
in fact the validation error is going
down the other thing is very important
here is note that even though over the
Dacian air is going down which is what
we should care about this goes back to
Mitchell's question the validation loss
is actually increasing so if you're
going to keep track of when to stop by
keeping track of validation loss or the
training loss and the actual softmax
loss you're going to be mislead why is
the validation loss increasing because
again where they've verging towards
infinity so the norm of our predictor is
increasing so in those points we get
wrong we're suffering huge loss so over
here over here any the validation loss
is starting to increase even though the
validation error is still going down
right another two percent okay so and
then again now we can understand all
this directly from the theory okay now
we can okay John sure I'll take your
question then X is like more pieces
that's why we're getting this log do you
think so if we have it a loss that
decreases faster say like no but this
already the creases though you're not
what I mean this a crease is basically
just exponent this crease is very very
fast polynomial here something like this
instead of exponentially are we gonna
see something very different
I don't know so that's a good question
so I don't know so so not right right so
that this rate definitely comes from the
from the exponential from the
exponential tail of the derivative and
that's very possible and I don't know
right I actually think so I don't know
basically no this is not what the
spiders but okay sorry no so it's a good
question and I don't know okay so
squared loss doesn't okay squared loss
is not captured by this because squared
loss has a finite minimum you're now
going to converge to the maximum margin
solution with this cordless you're going
to converge to the minimum normal
solution for this cordless that's
different let's let me finish because
this is the last slide so I just want to
finish this so we can actually okay so
now of course the reason this is
interesting is not so much because they
carry exactly about the just aggregation
although I can we already saw that we we
can explain the air phenomena just
because we understand the speed of
convergence the max margin we can
understand what's going on but we can
use this as a basis to analyze other
things so so first of all we can talk
itself but we'll just take about
multi-class organizations like the
softmax that's pretty easy to analyze
and you get the exact same thing
converge to the multi to the multi-class
SVM
I can go back to the matrix
factorization problem and
it seems it's actually and instead of
talking about its exact same problem
instead of looking about the squared
loss to talk about a logistic loss and
it seems that it's actually easier to
understand this in this case and again
we can kind of show that you converge
here to the minimum nuclear norm
solution with the prediction margin of 1
you can also extend this then to
knowledge from linear neural networks in
London you know neural network so it
becomes more implicit in a bit more for
miss and you can also ask what happens
without a grant so again so this
convergence is not a special property of
the logistic loss it's the first
property of grainy descent if you
minimize so just a class with a degrade
you would converge to something which is
not the max margin solution you converge
to this red line and unlike this blue
line which is actually the max margin
solution and you can again ask where
does a degrade converge to on when
minimizing logistic regression problem
on square bus Jones yeah no very simple
question it's it's a it's a very very
reasonable question I believe it's
actually easily answerable okay so they
and again I want to I want to emphasize
you the differences between the squared
loss and logistic and part of the reason
I want to end I wanted to add with
logistic this is the one after last
night one of the reasons I wanted to end
with with logistic is because I think
that it's actually we've been working a
lot about the squared loss and when we
started thing about this metric
circularization problem we initially
thought about okay what happens for when
you minimize the squared off screen do
squared squared loss regression on the
metrics argument cuz that seems the most
natural but it's actually much harder it
seems that it's much harder to analyze
the logistic lost case there are some
tactics in the logistic loss case are
actually in some sense easier because
you don't since you're going the way to
infinity you don't care at all about
what happens in the beginning you don't
care about initialization you don't care
about the step size if you're running at
a grade you don't care about how all
your gradients accumulate in the
beginning you can forget all that all
that sometimes looks are given by the
fact that you're going far away from
origin so in some sense it's actually
easier to analyze for the four squared
loss or and again it's nothing here
special about the squared last ring
what's special is for a loss that's
actually has a minimum at a finite place
then you have to kind of do all the
the infinitesimal stuff yourself you
have to start talking about an infant
step infinitesimal step size you have to
start worrying about the initialization
what happens the beginning at a grad is
a halt pain to analyze because all the
first situations of a degrade are going
to completely change what you can
converge to it's a much bigger pain to
try noise so it turns out that for for
these monotone decreasing losses we get
it's I think a much better way of
studying these questions okay that was
actually the last line I'm gonna end
here and now you can then can continue
asking questions
[Applause]
[Applause]